Biden is trying to turn this news cycle
around the way he's going to turn it
around is by visiting the Border about
time showing that he's getting really
tough on illegal immigration Biden
tweets out quote our problems at the
border did not arise overnight and they
won't be solved overnight translation
I'm not actually going to do anything
about this but I want to see him really
serious I'm going to go visit the border
for the first time certainly since he's
been president I think maybe for the
first time in his entire political
career he's done some drive-bys by
border towns I'm not sure the man has
ever actually been down to the Border
proper until now he says we can come
together to fix this broken system we
can secure the border and fix the
immigration process to be orderly fair
safe and Humane there's a real irony
about the photo that he posts because
the photo features himself or Patrol
agents and it features the wall he's
taking the picture in front of two
things that this man has vilified
throughout his presidency